in the video on the fourth coalition I
forgot to add one super important
consequence of the treaties of Tilsit
and especially the Treaty of Tilsit with
Prussia I already talked about that it
was all about carving up Prussia and
really humiliating Prussia and really
removing it from the status of one of
one of the pre-eminent powers and all I
talked about was the loss of the Western
the territories of pressure west of the
Elbe and that's about that area right
there but just as important as that the
polish holdings of prussia so all of
this area right up let me all of this
area right over here this also was
removed from Prussia and became a French
satellite state and became the Duchy of
Warsaw Duchy of Warsaw so I just really
want to emphasize the Treaty of Tilsit I
only emphasize it's kind of what
happened on the western side of Russia
but the eastern side of Prussia also got
carved up and Prussia essentially lost
half of its half of its size so very
dramatic humiliation for Prussia at the
end of the Treaty of Tilsit or the
treaties of Tilsit now with that out of
the way we talked about in the last
video that the end of the fourth
coalition napoleon was kind of near the
peak of his power he had kind of done
everything right he had this kind of
steady upward momentum in his in in or
France had a steady upward momentum and
it's in its power but we're going to see
in this video or is at least the
beginnings of the downfall of Napoleon
you're not going to it's not going to be
obvious when you look at the territory
because it's from a territorial point of
view going to see in this video that
he's actually gaining territory but he's
going to start doing some of the actions
that end up undermining him so we talked
about in the last video we talked about
this whole notion of the Continental
System Continental Continental system
where Napoleon was obsessed with people
on the continent of Europe boycotting
England not not trading with England and
he figured this was the only way that he
could really undermine England's
dominance on the ocean or
undermined or eventually maybe even
undermine England generally so he was
very you know as we said the treaties of
Tilsit he got Russia to participate in
the Continental System so he wanted
everyone to buy into it and one party
that at this point we're talking about
where in 1807 now we are in 1807 now one
party that wasn't all that keen in
participating in the Continental System
was Portugal that's Portugal right there
so Napoleon goes and chats well you know
they didn't chat directly but he gets
the agreement of the king of Spain this
is Charles the fourth and he's going to
look like a bit of a fool in this video
so this is Charles this is Charles
the fourth Napoleon says hey Charles
let's go in there let's go into Portugal
that little upstart country that doesn't
want to participate the Continental
System you and me will invade together
we'll bring them into kind of our our
realm of influence and you know we can
both kind of pillage the lands and and
get the wealth of Portugal Charles the
fourth he's all up for this so he so a
combined French and Spanish force invade
Portugal so in 1807 this is the end of
eighteen cents actually October write
this down in October you have a combined
French and Spanish invasion invasion of
Portugal and they are able to take
Portugal but we're going to see that
it's reasonably temporary now I just
mentioned that this guy is going to look
like the fool of this video and the
reason is is because for with the excuse
of reinforcements obviously obviously to
get to Portugal you have to go through
Spain so with the excuse of sending in
reinforcements Napoleon in 1808 this is
an 1808 and now we're talking about
early 1808 in particular in March so the
excuse of sending in reinforcements to
support the Portugal campaign and sprain
is like oh you're my ally yeah sure send
those hundred thousands of troops right
through our territory we're not going to
worry about it with the Lexx with that
excuse Napoleon was able to send a
hundred
the troops and occupy Madrid and occupy
Madrid so this is one of those lessons
of never get too greedy this guy got
greedy wanted to help Napoleon or even I
guess the other lesson is be careful who
your friends are
this guy wanted to invade Portugal but
the the side effect of it is that Madrid
gets occupied and that actually he gets
dethroned and and so you know you have
this the situation here the French are
now in control of Spain in May in May of
1808 in May of and this and and this is
really going to be the first little
spark that is kind of the downfall of
Napoleon in May May 2nd May 2nd 1808 a
popular uprising starts in Madrid sink
those DeMayo so popular uprising in
Madrid popular uprising and at the same
time a little bit after that so you know
you can imagine this is a hugely
tumultuous time you have you know you
have this I guess an occupation of
Portugal with the excuse of
reinforcements in March the French
troops occupy Madrid q PI Madrid then in
May so in you know a couple of months
later a popular uprising starts in
Madrid this leads to popular uprisings
throughout Spain but at the very same
time is this this is a little bit after
the uprising in May Napoleon says oh we
know this is just a little uprising I'm
still in control of spit of Spain he he
appoints his other brother remember he
does this whole business he's putting
his brothers in charge of different
parts of the Empire he puts his brother
he puts his brother Joseph he puts his
he appoints his brother Joseph or you
could kind of say he inserts his brother
Joseph as the king of Spain as the king
of Spain King of Spain
so this is all in kind of you know early
mid 1808 Spain is in all of this you
know turmoil
a new king has been appointed who's
Napoleon's brother the old king is no
longer in charge you have this you you
have an ongoing battle in Portugal they
don't have a firm hold on Portugal just
yet and in the rest of 1808 the the the
uprising that occurs throughout Spain is
actually pretty successful in enforcing
the French troops to to retreat so
French retreat so then there's a French
retreat French retreat and a major I
guess aspect of this of this uprising is
this it's one of the first real national
uprisings in history where you know it's
it's it's people are saying we are
Spanish we do not like being controlled
by the French we do not like how they
have treated our royalty we as a as a
nation are going to rise up and the
other interesting aspect of this whole
uprising that it starts starts in Madrid
with those DeMayo but then it starts
continuing throughout the whole nation
is the idea of guerrilla warfare
guerrilla warfare not guerrilla warfare
korilla guerrilla warfare and this comes
from the Spanish for it little war
guerrilla not from the the the large ape
and what it implies and you've probably
heard the word on the news before is
kind of a non-conventional style of
fighting where a small little groups
kind of engage their enemy and very
non-traditional style so it becomes a
very painful at least for Napoleon's
forces it became very difficult fighting
this these non-conventional battles all
over Spain so they were able to force
the French to retreat Napoleon says gee
you know what if you if you want a job
well done you got to do it yourself so
Napoleon comes in at the end of the year
and then he retakes Madrid so December
of 1808 in December Napoleon Napoleon
back in Madrid back in Madrid now you
might say always you know fine and well
now Napoleon is
back here he has firm control of Spain
but not everything is good because as
you could imagine there's all these
other characters here that keep forming
coalition's for and against Napoleon I
mean even when they say that their
allied you know in the back of their
minds they can't wait until they can
declare the next declare the next war on
Napoleon
so in 1809 in 1809 let me write this
down
1809 in 1809 Austria declares war
Austria declares war and since Great
Britain was isn't this at this point in
time perpetual war with France this
becomes the fifth coalition declares war
and this is the fifth coalition but this
one is fairly short-lived Napoleon says
gee I got I got you know these guys on
my Eastern Front
you know Austria's is is read Eclair war
on me so he leaves Spain to go lead that
fight and he leaves three hundred
thousand of his best troops in Spain to
hold Spain and frankly this is the most
important side effect of the fifth
coalition is that it Lala it makes
Napoleon go to fight Austria to lead
that effort as opposed to worrying about
Spain and essentially by doing that it
allows and I don't know if it's
necessarily the fact that Napoleon
wasn't there but the it could be because
Napoleon wasn't there is that Spain just
becomes a major thorn in Napoleon side
this guerrilla warfare just continues on
and on and on and it just goes back and
forth and the French will win a battle
and they'll win another battle but they
still don't have control and these
guerrillas will kind of peck at them and
continue the uprising and this really
just drains the French army and really
just gets at them a little bit by a
little bit really over the the remainder
of Napoleon's reign so all the way until
18 to 14 we haven't gone over that yet
but this this occurs all the way to 1814
so I said at the beginning of the video
this is one of the the starting points
of Napoleon's downfall that's just
because he was just stuck in Spain he
was just stuck in Spain from 1808
on just continuing to have to send
troops and supplies and reinforcements
and and wealth to support what they call
the Peninsular campaign the Peninsular
campaign and it just drains him it
drains his resources it drains his
energy and it really hurts his ability
to fight a Wars with all of the other
people who he needs to fight wars with
this is one of the major downfalls the
other one which we'll probably talk in
either the next video or a video after
that is his invasion of Russia which he
does in 1812 and that that's super that
that that that you know the one could
debate which one drains of France's
resources more but the invasion of
Russia really decimates Napoleon's
forces and really makes him susceptible
to to really conquest by England and all
of the other allies so we're going to
see that in a couple of videos so you
have this Peninsular campaign continuing
to drain Napoleon he was you know it all
started because he wanted to enforce the
Continental system on Portugal and you
got a little bit of greedy and he also
wanted to conquer Spain and just uh just
to highlight why it's called the
Peninsular campaign this right here a
little bit of geography this is called
the Iberian Peninsula right there that
I'm circling so you could call it the
Iberian Peninsula campaign because it's
everything that's going on on this
peninsula and Spain and Portugal Iberian
Peninsula Peninsula been in let me write
that little pin in Silla now if we back
up a little bit back to 1808 where we
had this uprising in Spain and they were
able to push the French back at the same
time you also had a popular uprising in
Portugal in late roughly in the fall in
the late summer or fall of 1808 the
British got excited they saw it as their
chance to push Napoleon out of Portugal
so you have this gentleman right here
Sir Arthur Wellesley
he's a future Duke of Wellington and
he's eventually going to be responsible
for pushing Napoleon out of Spain
entirely or at least out of Madrid so
this is Sir Arthur
sir arthur wellesley he him and long
with the british and along with the
portuguese are able to push the french
out in august of 1808 so let me put this
in art in my not so neatly drawn
timeline here so the december napoleon
is back so right before that in august
august out of portugal out of portugal
and this is another motivation for
napoleon to say gee you know what things
aren't going well on the Iberian
Peninsula I have to take charge of
things myself now at the very same time
is all of this is happening and this is
really just kind of out of interest you
could imagine that well it's more than
out of interest because it actually has
you know huge global repercussions you
might say okay well okay you have this
Iberian Peninsula Spain is going back
and forth between the French and the
gorillas and you you know Portugal has
this whole situation where their King
was dethroned but then the British help
and take it back but you could imagine
that these nations are in just a super
state of flux in a super state of flux
now you could also imagine I mean these
the king of Spain wasn't just the king
of Spain he was king of the Spanish
Empire and the Spanish Empire this I
mean the main conch the main landmass of
the Spanish Empire was in the Americas
so this right here that was the Spanish
Empire at the time this was a 400 year
old Spanish Empire all from you know
starting with you know club Columbus
sailing the ocean blue in 1492 he had
this huge Spanish Empire and and one of
the really important side effects of
Napoleon invading Spain and having this
long protracted engagement in Spain is
it it catalyzed the ability of these
colonies at the time to start looking
for their independence we're going to do
whole videos on that in the future but
this really is one of the things that
allowed them to get independence but you
know obviously if the Empire is in flux
these guys can say hey gee we don't have
you know why do we have to listen to
that to that to that nation anymore that
we don't even know who's in charge there
at the same time same thing in Portugal
Brazilian independence didn't come until
a little bit later after this period but
this is Napoleon's invasion is what
really sparked the
beginning of a lot of turmoil in
Portugal and that eventually is one of
the causes that leads to the eventual
independence of Brazil that doesn't
happen for another ten or fifteen years
but this is you could imagine this is
where a lot of that action can be traced
back now another interesting point that
occurred around around this time and
actually I didn't tell you what happened
on the fifth coalition I said Austria
declared war obviously Britain was
already at war so it was the fifth
coalition Napoleon had to leave that
maybe made Spain a little bit harder to
hold for France and that's why it kind
of bled France slowly but Napoleon was
able to take care of Austria and then he
was able to take a little bit more land
from them actually gallaecia this area
of Austria was given to the Duchy of
Warsaw which was a French satellite
state and then Austria once again had to
say oh gee Napoleon where your friend
we're going to do whatever you ask us to
so you could imagine it this time land
wise the Empire of Napoleon seemed
pretty dramatic you know you could you
could include Spain here although he had
to spend a lot of resources to keep
Spain and then now we had Austria at
least was in the fold
you know Prussia was not really happy
about it but this whole area here kind
of this the the the western half of
Poland was under French control Germany
you know the Confederacy of the Rhine
which is now Germany and then a good bit
of Italy the kingdom of nidalee Italy
was also a a French satellite state but
Napoleon of course you know he he wanted
everyone to participate in the
Continental system that's the only way
to really strangle England and the papal
states were not participating in the
Continental system so the papal States
right there were not participating in
the Continental system so they you know
he sent some people over to kind of try
to convince them to and when when they
didn't they occupied the papal States
so French troops occupy the papal States
and once again this we're going in this
was still back in 1808 it was actually
early 1808 it's just on a different
front so in February up here in 1808
actually that's before they even
occupied Madrid so in 1808
February French troops
occupy papal States occupy papal States
they essentially give them over to the
Kingdom of Italy which at that time was
a French satellite state so it's almost
like annexing into France and then once
the fifth coalition was done with
Napoleon felt so good about himself that
he formally annexed the papal States -
and then now we're in 1809 in 1809 he
formally he formally so this is 1809
1809 the papal states are actually
annexed into the French Empire papal
States annexed now you can imagine that
the Pope wasn't that happy about this
this is the Pope at the time this is
Pius the seventh Pius Pius the seventh
he wasn't so happy about it so he
excommunicates Napoleon and I'll do a
whole video on excommunication but it's
really about as bad as something you
could do to someone within the powers of
the Catholic Church and by implication
you're no longer part of the church and
you will probably go to hell now at
least if the Pope has anything to do
with it so the you know Napoleon wasn't
happy about this he sent some people
some officers once again talked to the
Pope about it say hey gee why do you
want to communicate
Napoleon why don't you just play nice
why don't you just you know you know
agreed whatever Napoleon says the Pope
doesn't agree and so he gets abducted
this is why it's interesting Napoleon he
sees you know he's he's not afraid to
take some serious action so he gets
abducted in 1809 by French officers
abducted abducted in 1809 by French
officers and it's not clear that it's
not obvious that Napoleon told them to
do it but once he was abducted they
actually started shuttling him around or
all around France depending on who
needed to talk to him or you know where
you know if they was afraid that the
British would might try to free him from
one port they would send him someplace
else but it wasn't clear that Napoleon
ordered this but he never ordered his
release so in some ways you got to say
that it was sanctioned by Napoleon so
all of this mess starts you know
Napoleon's messing with the Pope he is
this ongoing a bleeding going on in
Spain and that ends actually in 1812
where Sir Arthur Wellesley finally
retakes Madrid but in during this whole
period you can imagine it's really
draining into the resources of the
French of the French Empire